[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, morning of the third of Wealsun after the battle with Sahaugin, after Tyrus threw the solution into the Smuggaloos Caves of Helm Island, the party sits on the docks, basically recovering from what they're doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to see where you're at?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you guys want to have a conversation?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can anybody heal?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can anybody get any heals at all?
[SPEAKER_05]: Why did you say that?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm fucked up, but I'm okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need to rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: I run up and grab Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can we see if there's a ship coming towards us or leaving?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can we see anything from the docks?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I see anything from where I'm posted as well?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like to count how many barrels we got.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you go up and Paul Ribeiro goes up to the barrels and counts the number that are out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are... 25.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, that'll give us about 50-50.
[SPEAKER_02]: I grab all 25.
[SPEAKER_02]: 25 barrels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um... You drank a whole barrel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Some red eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I, uh... Gouge drinks a red eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to go over here and see if I had that drinking thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Somebody want to check out these tents?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: I would love to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we're going to cut to the chase.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, the tents are obviously places where there are some weapons that are basically kept for you don't know what.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are the same kind of weaponry and armor that the hobgoblins had.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, this is kind of one of their depots, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: So they came up, put the tents up, had their weaponry and stuff started.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we've got to get ready for that ship to come back because if they're trying to take everything off and there's 25 more barrels,
[SPEAKER_04]: We don't have time to rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: That ship's got to come back and we have to take it, take the barrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you guys want to station up here and start a short rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: By the ballista?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we start taking those barrels up there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we march those?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I think the barrels...
[SPEAKER_01]: If we see the ship coming, we can get to the barrels before they...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think what we need to do is reload this, have the archer up here, and... Actually, you know, if the ship comes and it's a lot of armed guys, they could take the barrel one for us.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, moving them out of the area might not be... That's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get them up by the... We should go, like, move the barrels up here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Move the barrels up there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, we could do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: We could do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, and the deal is, is that...
[SPEAKER_03]: They've got 25 barrels here.
[SPEAKER_03]: How far up here can we see and still see in a ship come in?
[SPEAKER_00]: If the ballista is there, can it see a ship coming in here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: The ballista is made for covering the docks and the entrance into the... You can be able to pull these fucking bodies out and throw them in the tent or something?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, there's dozens of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, I was going to say, they're going to see all the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, they're going to see they're all floating.
[SPEAKER_04]: But they'll already, I think, be coming into it.
[SPEAKER_04]: If the cave is darker than the outside daylight,
[SPEAKER_04]: They're coming in.
[SPEAKER_04]: They won't notice it until they're already coming in.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but this is going to spread all the way out about.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm less worried about the bodies.
[SPEAKER_04]: I do think if they overwhelm us, we need to secure the barrel.
[SPEAKER_04]: So maybe moving the barrels up to here at least, we can do that quickly.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get that thing loaded and then some of us be ready on the landing and some of us be ready up here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because if we can take that ship,
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys might be able to take that ship and, well, fuck it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now I guess we don't have any Lord Farrowin or any Toli.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do we burn the bridge or the planks that we came in on so there are no hobgoblins from there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, since we don't have a Lord Farrowin, we can spend some time searching, like 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if we don't have a Lord Fairwind, we could take all the barrels, destroy that, work our way up, still try to find and release Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_04]: He said that there was some hobgoblin guards.
[SPEAKER_04]: He kind of told us where his troops were locked.
[SPEAKER_04]: They just weren't armed.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we would have to kill the guards for the interior.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we can still take over the island and we can hold this island with 25 barrels, at least against the sahaugin, which the Toli aren't ready to storm it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I do want to go back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, like we could secure this island and hold it for at least 50 days.
[SPEAKER_05]: You're talking the island.
[SPEAKER_05]: The island's got a lot more.
[SPEAKER_05]: We only barely did anything on the other part of the island.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, but he, well, the Lord Fair one said one barrel does it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, we probably overdid it in this quay right here or whatever this, this thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: But we could probably use half of a barrel.
[SPEAKER_04]: Signal, because we'll have, if we can take the main thing, then we can signal Monmurg to send us reinforcements, but we'll have roughly almost two months, or roughly close to two months, to secure whatever the hell else we need to secure.
[SPEAKER_00]: So my question is this, can the party enter combat at this point in time?
[SPEAKER_00]: How many spells are left?
[SPEAKER_00]: I cannot.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does a short rest replenish spells?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, some characters do get that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bards do not.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got only first level spells, one second level spell, and cantrips.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't have anything else.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna use my last five here.
[SPEAKER_04]: How wounded are you guys like this?
[SPEAKER_04]: I can survive maybe one good sword swing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think I can handle that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're fine?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what Merrick does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep my distance.
[SPEAKER_04]: So why don't we do this?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm at nine hit points.
[SPEAKER_04]: So why don't we actually just, you know what?
[SPEAKER_03]: I need to rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think, especially if Kane totally is out there with the Ghost, we're not going to be able to do anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: Unless he's got a huge contingent, we would have roughly 300 guys, depending upon like, you know, the outside guys, the inside guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: What about the Marines?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, that's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: So there's 150 on the outside, roughly minus 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's 150 guys that Lord Fairwind said he didn't want to have them injured, that we just need to get them to the armory.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's burn that bridge and let's get all the barrels back up and let's... Why do you think Lord Fairwind's guys will listen to us?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because they didn't know about them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, the same way the Lord Fairwind guys listen to us.
[SPEAKER_04]: At the other side.
[SPEAKER_04]: They know that he's a representative of Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but the only difference between those guys and Lord Farrow and the guys in the castle is... No, he had them taken...
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think that he had them in on his shit.
[SPEAKER_04]: You heard how arrogant he was.
[SPEAKER_04]: He didn't have, like, his troopers in on the know.
[SPEAKER_04]: Otherwise, we would have to fight our way through them or they wouldn't even be locked up.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think we can release because we know that the 150 on the outside, we're demonstrating in the front.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if we find them locked up, we can talk to them first.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't just be like...
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if we get the lighthouses and we can signal it to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he said he got them in their barracks, basically.
[SPEAKER_04]: He said they weren't locked up in jail.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right, he wanted them safe, but they weren't armored.
[SPEAKER_04]: So all of their shit, it was basically a few guys might have gotten killed that were on guard duty, but it sounded like the bulk of the interior guard
[SPEAKER_04]: Our behind locked doors.
[SPEAKER_05]: That'll guard it.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would buy that if he was under duress and said, we will leave your people alone.
[SPEAKER_05]: We want all the barrels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll make a deal with it.
[SPEAKER_05]: You guys can take it.
[SPEAKER_04]: But that's what I think he was doing.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_05]: Paul said he was in cahoots with them and said that he is guilty.
[SPEAKER_05]: Paul, what did you hear?
[SPEAKER_04]: Why would his guys... Yeah, what did you hear, Paul?
[SPEAKER_04]: What did you hear?
[SPEAKER_05]: Paul, Merrick, I actually started doing the job.
[SPEAKER_02]: Adrian, what exactly did I hear from Fairwind talking to him?
[SPEAKER_00]: They were talking about making deals or...
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you're coming with me because, of course, you can make whatever kind of shit you want up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's what this game is about, is that, you know, Paul is probably going to tell you the truth, but he is a noble.
[SPEAKER_05]: From a different...
[SPEAKER_00]: So who knows?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, I had to do that because, you know, you did hear it from the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, if you go back and read...
[SPEAKER_00]: The thing I created for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is your ears only, and you only agree about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically what he said was that he and the Toli were splitting the stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Splitting this stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Natoli said, well we noticed you took most of the shit anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: But that's good on you, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: We just don't want Monmurg to have any of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what you think Fairwind was doing was he wanted to be able to blame somebody else.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he's part of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the deal is that if the Toli are involved in this, and Fairwind is involved in this,
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, there's a coalition of people against Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like Fairwind said in the conversation, these are all princes.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're all kind of co-equal in the nation.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's not like they don't have conflict between them.
[SPEAKER_00]: But this is screwed up, because this is Sahaugin doing their thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and he's trying to screw over Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the reason this nation exists was because of the Toli, the Outer Islands, and the Duke of Birkhoff all coming together and beating the Sahaugin 150 years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is an eternal conflict, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's obvious Fairwind did not want to show his hand
[SPEAKER_00]: He wanted it to be between the Toli and Monmurg, but he wanted Monmurg to lose.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But he didn't want to show himself yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so it wouldn't be...
[SPEAKER_00]: He didn't want to show himself dealing with the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: He didn't want to show which side he was on.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so the men getting locked down and him not letting all of his men, because obviously he'll have a couple of men on, these guys down here, the guys that Gouge and Tyrus killed, these are Fairwind's personal guard.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there are some people close to Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_00]: That know this and are dealing with this, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But you wouldn't be surprised if Aaron was trying to act like, oh, I thought I was taken by surprise, blah, blah, blah, and then just say that Toli took everything, even though he took a lot of it himself, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But it would take, you know, probably wouldn't take attention off him, but it might cause enough doubt
[SPEAKER_00]: In Jeon's mind to not really know who his real allies are.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is very concerning, though, because, you know, Fairwind does this, a guy from the Outer Islands who normally side with Jeon, this situation is bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keoland is making a power play, big time.
[SPEAKER_00]: And when you came in the room after you listened to him, he was trying to act like he was a prisoner.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you have hit dies left to roll, so you get three short rests a day, and then you have to take a long rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: But every short rest you can roll as many hit dies as you have to heal up points.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're fourth level, or third level, so you have three die eights.
[SPEAKER_00]: So every time you take a short rest you can use one, two, or three of those,
[SPEAKER_00]: But if you use three of them, they're all gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can't do it again until you take a long rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if you're high level, it's really cool for like, you know, okay, I got Tin Die Tin.
[SPEAKER_00]: I lose like 20 hit points.
[SPEAKER_00]: I rest a short rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: I roll 2 die 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm totally healed up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do it again.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can go all day.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, you know, at the end of the day, okay, I'm really wiped out now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can do a short rest, a long rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I use my song of rest every short rest of the day?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or is it just a one time?
[SPEAKER_00]: I read that.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think short rest will allow you to do the song of rest and give that extra die six in there.
[SPEAKER_05]: My rest would be six as a rogue and one as a fighter.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you have six die eight and then one die ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then plus eight for my other stone.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then you get an extra one die eight because you have that resting stone.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can use that and you can use that one every short rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: So automatically you've got a one die eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you have a friendly creature who can hear your performance regain hit points at the end of a short rest by spending one or more hit die, each of those creatures get an extra d6.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they have to roll at least one, but then they get the extra.
[SPEAKER_03]: They get an extra d6 on top of that.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's definitely something you want to do.
[SPEAKER_05]: How long is the short rest?
[SPEAKER_04]: One hour.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I think that because we were worried about if Lord Fairwind survived,
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to get to his troops before he gets to his troops.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I don't think that we can rest just yet.
[SPEAKER_04]: I really don't.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, I think that we're not ready for combat, but I think that if we can get 150 guys, we kill some of the hobgoblins and we get them up to the armory, then I think we're going to lose the initiative.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can keep going.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you just... Can you protect barrels and guard?
[SPEAKER_05]: I can go.
[SPEAKER_03]: You want to go?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, maybe you stay... Yeah, and if something pops up out of the thing... Well, no, no sahaugin are going to pop up.
[SPEAKER_04]: It would just be, you could fire the ballista and then haul back up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where are you guys going to go, then?
[SPEAKER_04]: We've got to go try to release the troops because, look, I'd love to think that Lord Fairwind is dead, but he's too smart.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so if he's going to go somewhere, the only direction he's going to go is this way.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he's not going to go out.
[SPEAKER_04]: He has to.
[SPEAKER_03]: The tide was going out.
[SPEAKER_05]: You want to check the belly of the beast?
[SPEAKER_05]: That's what I said.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's why I wanted him to pull the shark up.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can try to pull the shark up.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, the 40-footer.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it was a 40-footer, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, we can still try to pull it.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's floating.
[SPEAKER_04]: We can still try to pull it up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's the question, guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you willing to leave the barrels by themselves?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or be defended by one guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two of us, I think, are going to leave.
[SPEAKER_04]: All of us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I mean, yeah, we can leave.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two of us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, I've still got...
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, we're going to split the party?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are these up here now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we and Folsom have been working this entire time.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it moved the barrels up to the upper end.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what happened, it was a hard workout.
[SPEAKER_05]: We're talking one hour, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well Merrick's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: He knows the island.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can go with him.
[SPEAKER_05]: If we, like Jude's saying, we've got to get to the guys, but I don't know how, we can't get through any hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_05]: We're talking about one hour.
[SPEAKER_05]: We encounter those 12 guards outside the Sanctum Sanctorum, we're fucked.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, he didn't say 12, he just said that they were guarded, his troops were guarded.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he said that there were two squads of hobgoblins guarding those people.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's 40 dudes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, look, if we at least hauled ass back, but he said there's like, he said there's multiple ways back, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Like, isn't there, he said there's multiple ways down here.
[SPEAKER_04]: We haven't been through the bars.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know where that goes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I mean, like, we gotta, look, I don't like it, and yes, it puts us all close to death.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, if we end up with Lord Fairwind's troops against us, the best thing that he can do is kill us all so that nobody is there to tell the truth.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what we're up against.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if we take an hour-long break so that we're all...
[SPEAKER_03]: So where is he gonna go from here then?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, I don't know how many places he said, but if he went out, he could get on the beach and he could be talking to his own troops on the outside.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he could say, these guys are all traitors.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like us.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he made it on the inside and he climbed up the rocks... Where's the overall map that you had that big map of the whole island?
[SPEAKER_03]: Since we might be right under the edge there, since the waters are clear, sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we're talking about he has to come out here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so he can either come out and come back around and talk to his troops that are demonstrating out in the front.
[SPEAKER_04]: Remember, they're out in front.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has to come out, he has to survive sharks and sahuagins and everything else, come out here,
[SPEAKER_03]: Climb up this wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, he doesn't have to go inside.
[SPEAKER_04]: He can go and talk to his troops that are demonstrating out front.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, this is all full of hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: Remember his troops from there?
[SPEAKER_04]: We had 150 troops and they were building and building fires.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't even know what they were taking.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: They just sent some guys out to make a... We can talk hypotheticals all we want, but we know there's troops we gotta find.
[SPEAKER_04]: What I'm saying is that these troops here came up to here to make a distraction.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he comes out and he gets to the beach here, these are his troops.
[SPEAKER_04]: He will have roughly 150 troops that he will re-command.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he goes inside, there's roughly 150 troops of Lord Fairwinds that he had locked up.
[SPEAKER_04]: And hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_03]: How do we know that the hobgoblins are going to follow him?
[SPEAKER_04]: Screw the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe he has his men kill the hobgoblins because the gig's up.
[SPEAKER_04]: The problem is, we're part of the gig.
[SPEAKER_04]: He'll kill us in like seconds.
[SPEAKER_03]: And what if we have a whole ship come back through here full of people and everything else and you've got two of us trying to guard the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're still all screwed.
[SPEAKER_03]: Everything's dead.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean there are fish that are dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like this stuff kills all kinds of aquatic creatures.
[SPEAKER_00]: So all you gotta do is take that ship from your fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whether it's me and a ballista or one guy and the rest of you guys go up top.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a lot of dead.
[SPEAKER_04]: But what we need to do is we need to get control of his men and keep a lookout for him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, we can cut the belly of the beast open, but let's say there ain't no Lord Fairwood in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then we know we have to go find him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so let's drag that motherfucking fish in.
[SPEAKER_04]: But here's the thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who's resting and who's moving barrels?
[SPEAKER_04]: We already moved all the barrels.
[SPEAKER_04]: You already did?
[SPEAKER_00]: How much time did it take?
[SPEAKER_00]: It took about 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: See, we gotta go in.
[SPEAKER_04]: We gotta go in.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's already been 30 minutes and we've been talking and the air bike moved all the barrels.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, I'll go.
[SPEAKER_03]: I couldn't.
[SPEAKER_04]: I do not think this is- Okay, then take a nap next to the ballista with somebody who's not taking a nap.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is a suggestion, since all the sahaugin are dead from the area that we lost Lord Farron, could we go where Lord Farron, where we lost him, and see if there's any secret passages or any exits that he could have done?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, sure, but that's all gonna take time.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm saying take command of his men.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, now, and kill.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the problem with taking care of Merrick and his men, I'm just gonna say this, is there are hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's right, in between.
[SPEAKER_04]: In control of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know that, but unless we're gonna sneak our ass, look, if he is dead, then all of this is academic, and we can wait days, and it's no big deal.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, but...
[SPEAKER_04]: The problem that I have is we have no way off this island.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have no way off this island.
[SPEAKER_04]: And Lord Fairwind knows who each of us are.
[SPEAKER_03]: Climb on the beach, survive all the hobgoblins, make his way to his men and go, hey guys, wait, we're gonna go search for these other dudes down in the caves real quick.
[SPEAKER_04]: By the time he does all that, an hour can usually pass.
[SPEAKER_04]: We represent a bigger threat to him than the damn hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can guarantee we are his biggest threat.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is going to find and kill us.
[SPEAKER_04]: We may be all near death, but if we don't...
[SPEAKER_03]: He has so much attitude, he doesn't even care about that.
[SPEAKER_03]: The best part of his life is he has some barrels hidden way off in the west.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's the only last 25, so he only knows he's only gonna be a little bit left.
[SPEAKER_03]: So best case scenario, he floats his ass out.
[SPEAKER_04]: He floats his ass out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he knows what?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he already knows.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's already gonna have a conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if he's not working with us, we're gonna get back and talk to Lord Jamison about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, but we don't have a way.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't have a way off this island.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's Tyrus's intelligence?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm a smart motherfucker, okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Tyrus knows a thing or two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he's already got all the cards as it is right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Actually, he's even in a better position than when we had him before because we don't know and at this point we take a small rest and get healed up.
[SPEAKER_04]: But that's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, but he's going to kill us all and we don't have a way off this island.
[SPEAKER_03]: He doesn't even need to kill us all.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, he does.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he doesn't.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: He does need to kill us all.
[SPEAKER_04]: He knows that he's a representative of Lord Jeon.
[SPEAKER_04]: He knows that he's your Axeman.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: He knows I'm an agent.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I sent my homoculi in the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was making deals with the Toli, basically was saying, exchanging about, you can take the rest of the barrels.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because he was already taking the barrels.
[SPEAKER_04]: He admitted to that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Was he tied up when he was making the deal?
[SPEAKER_04]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_04]: He wasn't tied up.
[SPEAKER_04]: He was not tied up.
[SPEAKER_04]: So they tied him up as a ruse.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which means he was totally in on it.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, he was trying to double-cross the dam totally because he's been screwing over Jeon already for the last month.
[SPEAKER_02]: How I was able to interpret it is he's trying to screw over Monmurg and he's also trying to keep his hand hidden for himself.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's all the princes for themselves.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the Tali and the rest of the principalities fight over and he gets away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: They want Monmurg fault.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that's gonna happen whether he kills us or not.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, okay, but I don't want to get killed.
[SPEAKER_04]: So when you say whether he kills us or not...
[SPEAKER_02]: If he kills us, then he gets away with it.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was more than happy.
[SPEAKER_02]: He gets away with it because the Toli guys are dead too.
[SPEAKER_02]: They assume that we just smoke.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hang on, one other time.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to hear you each make your own point.
[SPEAKER_03]: He wanted to go talk to your uncle anyway.
[SPEAKER_03]: He wanted to go talk to your uncle anyway, period.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he did.
[SPEAKER_03]: He said, oh, I'll talk to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'd be more than happy to.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's only because we caught him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Am I right?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's only because we caught him though.
[SPEAKER_03]: That doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_03]: He wants to go to him with this power.
[SPEAKER_04]: His hands aren't down if we get killed.
[SPEAKER_03]: I hope his pants are down.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, his pants aren't down.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's not exposed.
[SPEAKER_04]: He is exposed.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's going to use this to extort.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we get killed, there's no exposure.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's going to use this to extort already.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he could kill every hobgoblin on the island if we're dead, and he could say he defeated a Toli push to take the helm, and he is sweet and he is floating crystal clean.
[SPEAKER_04]: And still at this point- All he's got to have is every hobgoblins, guys, and we die.
[SPEAKER_02]: The hobgoblins aren't going to do it?
[SPEAKER_03]: His own shirts don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: But again, why would he take the barrels away if this wasn't a play to begin with?
[SPEAKER_03]: This was his play to begin with.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, it is a play.
[SPEAKER_04]: What I'm saying is that the gig is up.
[SPEAKER_04]: So now, you've got to kill every fucking witness.
[SPEAKER_04]: We are the witnesses.
[SPEAKER_05]: We are the number one-
[SPEAKER_05]: Public enemy in his eye right now, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dude, and we don't have a boat to get off this damn island.
[SPEAKER_05]: Without us...
[SPEAKER_02]: He can say whatever happened, he can make anything up, and he is okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can lie.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm pretty sure, well, him and I are, I think, are equivalent.
[SPEAKER_04]: He could just say that Sahaugin killed the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: So let me ask you this question, if that is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it a good idea to fight through his hobgoblins, or the totally hobgoblins, and then go to contact his men, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is a better idea just to hide?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think hiding's too good of an option.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think finding his troops might be the best of the worst case scenario because I doubt all of his troops knew, and ultimately at the end his troops aren't going to fail when they're willing to Jamis.
[SPEAKER_04]: This island isn't big enough to hide.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, we could snake some barrels, and how many days does that buy us to save us from the Sahaugin?
[SPEAKER_04]: And if the Sahaugin come back after like, what, six days?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ultimately though, wait, it's the second day we've been here, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess, second day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roughly?
[SPEAKER_04]: Second day?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, it's been about a day.
[SPEAKER_00]: I should be back.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's what?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you came the 2nd of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the morning of the 3rd, so you guys have been here maybe 12 hours.
[SPEAKER_04]: We could try to hold up in the tower and signal Monmurg to come.
[SPEAKER_02]: Realistically, within another, at the end of the day and by midday tomorrow...
[SPEAKER_02]: Jeon is going to already be sending troops because I'm not.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what would happen if we hide.
[SPEAKER_04]: What if we try to take the signal tower inside the key?
[SPEAKER_04]: If we're not even trying to fight any of his men, release any of his men, but we take the signal tower that can signal to Monmurg, we would have to take it during the day.
[SPEAKER_04]: The signal's probably best seen at night.
[SPEAKER_04]: We would have to hold it.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we can take it and rest, but we would have to hold it, and then we could signal we have 25 barrels, the sahaugin...
[SPEAKER_00]: But you would have to leave the barrels here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could take a few barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or we could leave someone, or a couple of us, with the...
[SPEAKER_00]: The barrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if there was an attempt to retake the barrels and there were a couple of people here, how would that go?
[SPEAKER_00]: It wouldn't go well.
[SPEAKER_05]: How many people were on the skiff did we see when they're loading barrels and taking it and loading barrels?
[SPEAKER_00]: A skiff that size probably has a crew of maybe, it could be sailed by four and you can have up to maybe 20 people on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So wait, what are our options?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait for it to come back.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are our options for our next move?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, we could, but we do have to wait till dark.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that would mean we stay here.
[SPEAKER_04]: We say, fuck his troops.
[SPEAKER_05]: Rest until the next skiff comes in.
[SPEAKER_05]: Go down.
[SPEAKER_05]: Take the skiff.
[SPEAKER_05]: Load it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fight them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Load it, wait for night, and try to get the fuck back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know if we can wait for night, though, because those hobgoblins are gonna realize that their ship hasn't come with their necks.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's because Kane, Toli, is out there in a bigger ship, the Ghost, and that's gonna run us down.
[SPEAKER_04]: The only chance we have is at night.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can cast Darkness.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I could give us like maybe the size, but I mean it'll only disguise maybe the front prow and half the ship as we come out and give it nighttime.
[SPEAKER_02]: The only problem with darkness is that it's a dark cloud, so they're just going to see a big dark cloud move.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's better than seeing us though.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's better than seeing us.
[SPEAKER_04]: But we can't do it during the day.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can also do a smoke cloud that can kind of kick up a big area.
[SPEAKER_01]: A dark cloud and then a white cloud.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so if we were to do that, we could barricade
[SPEAKER_04]: The narrow hallway or burn that little thing down.
[SPEAKER_04]: But that is banking on the fact that that boat comes in and we load up the barrels and we get the fuck out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, there's 25 barrels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Obviously, they're gonna come back and get them.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we're at an advantage point.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they don't have Sahaugin helping them.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they maybe don't even know that we've taken them because there's no Sahaugin to warn them because we fucked up all the Sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have the giant crossbow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: We can like, we can totally, well, like you said, if there's only four to six guys even wounded, if we could rest and it takes four hours or whatever, great.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or an hour.
[SPEAKER_04]: All we need is an hour, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: But we still have to wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's like morning, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's approaching morning.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're about an hour away from dawn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it's like 6am, 5am, 4am.
[SPEAKER_04]: That means we can't even leave here until dark.
[SPEAKER_04]: What season is it?
[SPEAKER_04]: November-ish?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's more like late spring.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I mean like that means it's probably not going to get dark until 7.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we gotta take the ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_05]: And wait for like 12 hours.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which obviously would be a bigger problem because if that skiff doesn't go back within an hour of loading, then they're like, where the fuck's the skiff?
[SPEAKER_04]: Right, and they might send a little rowboat in, but they wouldn't have the numbers and we could fuck them up.
[SPEAKER_04]: But then they would be alerted.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, the big boat can't come in.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's why they have the skip.
[SPEAKER_04]: But they would be alerted that something was wrong.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if Lord Fairwind is alive and alerts his troops, we'll have his troops come in and he'll say that we're part of the Toli.
[SPEAKER_04]: He'll blame us as being part of the Tolis.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he'll say, like, oh, troops, go kill them.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're part of the Tolis.
[SPEAKER_04]: They blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or not even call us Tolis and call us pirates or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the way I see it, we have a couple of options.
[SPEAKER_02]: We, one, wait for the boat, get on it, try to get out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two,
[SPEAKER_02]: We hide on the island, but I don't know how well that'd work for us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or three, we try to contact with Fairwind's troops, and maybe, if we're lucky, we can get to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: As good as that sounds, I don't think we should leave the barrels unattended here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a really good advantage point where we can see what's coming in, and then we can also block off what was coming from the back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why do we need to hold on to the barrels?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because Monmurg also, Monmurg is under an embargo.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Monmurg can't just replace these barrels.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, that's exactly what Lord Farrowin was saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's been secreting barrels away to his own place.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we have one more area we haven't discovered through those bars.
[SPEAKER_02]: These barrels come in pretty regular supplies from...
[SPEAKER_02]: We could burn the bridge the way we came.
[SPEAKER_03]: We could burn that the way we came.
[SPEAKER_03]: The only way that they can attack us is either A from here or B where the gate is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Could we muscle the...
[SPEAKER_04]: The ballista down and shoot it up that entrance way that we came down in?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can it be maneuvered?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is the ballista only going to shoot down into the bay?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or could it be turn it around?
[SPEAKER_04]: You could flip it around and shoot up towards the stairway.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ballista in the hallway.
[SPEAKER_04]: That would fuck some shit up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it would for sure, but that's also, they're gonna only get one, one shot, but it's also one person at a time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, we could fireball and blow up the bridge if we need to.
[SPEAKER_05]: We burned that bridge where we came.
[SPEAKER_05]: Go explore behind the iron.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, if I had an hour, if I had an hour, I got tensors floating discs, so that means I can lift a lot of shit.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I can lift a lot of shit and drag it behind me.
[SPEAKER_04]: The problem is we don't know this place, so wherever we stash any barrels is not, I mean, it'll be found.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I don't recognize any of this part.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never been in this part of the cave.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, even if we went to the upper part, it'll be found.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just giving them enough time.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, we either, it seems to me, we either hunker down,
[SPEAKER_04]: Try to heal up, take the hour break that at least a lot of us need, or we push on and roll the fucking dice and try to take out and take control of his men and take the inner keep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Even if we take control of his men and he pops up somewhere, are they going to follow us?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, one of us would have to fucking kill him.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean like in front of his men.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it really depends.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, hopefully not in front of his men.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: With me here.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_02]: With me here, they're either going to listen to him or me.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that really depends upon the soldier and the captain.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, like, the guys on the outside garrison already know that he is an agent of Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like, didn't they already...
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm pretty sure that...
[SPEAKER_04]: So it might be weird, at least, if Lord Farrowind, they'd probably still do because they're Farrowind's troops.
[SPEAKER_00]: If Paul showed up and Farrowind was there and Farrowind said, seize him, they would do what he said.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: No doubt about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know if we ever dragged it in.
[SPEAKER_05]: I wanted to.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look, we've already spent 30 minutes with the barrel.
[SPEAKER_04]: We gotta make a decision.
[SPEAKER_04]: Even though we're not gonna play here.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I see the big shark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just floating there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't wait in to get it.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's in the middle of the stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: Throw some ropes.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can use a grappling hook to do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: We dragged the shark in so we can do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna go ahead and rest while they do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna tell you this will take hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, it will.
[SPEAKER_00]: This thing weighs
[SPEAKER_00]: Think about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just cut it up in the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I shoot the ballista at the shark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, if you wanted to shoot the ballista with a rope tied to it at the shark, you could probably do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I crawl into its mouth?
[SPEAKER_00]: You could absolutely do that if you wanted to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Its mouth is more than big enough to be able to crawl into it.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many ballista bolts are in there?
[SPEAKER_01]: There are 20 that are by the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to shoot at the shark.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a rope attached to it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you stick the shark with the rope.
Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you want to take a long rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or a short rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: While all this is going to go on, I'm going to take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: And a short rest is an hour?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's an hour.
[SPEAKER_03]: An hour.
[SPEAKER_03]: What are you going to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: How bad are you wounded?
[SPEAKER_03]: He's fine, so I'm going to short rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to gather around the people short resting and play my song of rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a good man.
[SPEAKER_03]: How many do you have left?
[SPEAKER_02]: I should take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this is the shark with an arrow stuck in it with a rope?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you stick the shark with the ballista bolt with a rope in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you begin trying to pull it in?
[SPEAKER_01]: How far down is the shark?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's about 50 feet away from where you are, but 20 feet down.
[SPEAKER_01]: You mean tie it off and then chim me down?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you could do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: The shark weighs it up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are you guys, are you guys doing the shark stuff?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's doing short stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: Everyone else is taking a short rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, we're not taking a short rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: Me and Paul are going to, we're gonna go up and try to see if we can keep bear wind.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're gonna sneak around.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can go invisible.
[SPEAKER_04]: He can be like hidden.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we can like go up to the number of levels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can't you just send the lizard guy around to look around?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, he can send the Humunculus, I can send the Toad.
[SPEAKER_04]: But we can go up further and we can at least try to see if we can intercept Lord Fairwind or identify at least if he's going for the troops on the inner side.
[SPEAKER_04]: We can't.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's too far away to see if he goes for the troops on the outside, but at least the troops on the outside already know that, like, Lord Jeon's family member is here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys are taking the short rest, and you guys are gonna go look and scout.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going down.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're going and investigating the chart.
[SPEAKER_00]: So let's do the short rest stuff first.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_05]: I just did it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I did a six die eight plus an extra die eight plus a one die ten plus one six.
[SPEAKER_05]: Jeez.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, I am only down six now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's in one hour?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's in one hour.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've got 62 hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: We operate as a failsafe, Jules.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus, how many points have you already used for your short rest?
[SPEAKER_00]: None.
[SPEAKER_00]: None, okay, great.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm going to use them all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, all three die 10 and one die 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: And one die 6.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I rolled 8, 8, 16, 26 back.
[SPEAKER_00]: 26 back, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm still... And then do you want to take a short rest, Folsom?
[SPEAKER_00]: You have no hit points off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you have no hit points off.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I haven't been hit yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: Unless...
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't get anything back with the short rest though.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe my barnic inspiration, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that there is something you get back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe barnic inspiration comes back with short rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's check that.
[SPEAKER_00]: And would my song of rest count as a short rest?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or would I be... You can do it as you're short resting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, actually, it's a level five bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, you have to finish a long rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, we're doing the rest first, then we're going to see what happens with you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so are you going to like watch or obey rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm playing my flute while they rest, so I...
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, are you doing that enhancement thing?
[SPEAKER_05]: And you're getting a rest, too.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, the summer rest.
[SPEAKER_05]: You get an extra six, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: A dice six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you need to do the enhancement?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because I haven't taken hardly any damage at all.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want me to go up there with my frog?
[SPEAKER_04]: Did you hear me?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you need to take the rest?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I mean, I'm down nine hit points.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not that much, bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I don't have that much.
[SPEAKER_05]: I know you don't have that.
[SPEAKER_05]: But a short rest, you get whatever you get back plus this die six from playing the flute, so you'd probably be perfect.
[SPEAKER_04]: You'd definitely be back up to full, probably with one of those.
[SPEAKER_04]: Definitely come down on the short rest, though.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have any spells that you used?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you don't, then I'd say take the nine and come with me, but you don't have to.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll take my nine.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want...
[SPEAKER_02]: I... You want to rest?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I want to rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, then I'll go by myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so Jude's gonna go by himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: You take your short rest, roll the die.
[SPEAKER_00]: One die...
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I need like four dollars.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_00]: And a one die six because of the song of rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight total, so you are down one hit point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, damn it.
[SPEAKER_05]: You did your rest.
[SPEAKER_05]: I did my rest.
[SPEAKER_05]: You're playing during the rest.
[SPEAKER_05]: No idea where you're going.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick, you shimmy down on this rope, which is 50 feet long.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're watching you do it, okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the entertainment, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're also waiting to see if a boat shows up, which is kind of important as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you get onto the shark and stand on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's kind of like a boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm standing on the shark.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much submersion?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like how much of the shark is up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like half the body is floating above?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say at least two-thirds of the body is up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two-thirds of the body is up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, no, I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two-thirds of the body is submerged.
[SPEAKER_00]: But that's still quite a bit of body.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is quite a bit of body.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it laying on its side?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it fin up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it belly up?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's belly up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Belly up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stand there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to cut into it enough where I can get in and see the stomach, but I don't want to do a long thing where it's going to sink it, you know what I'm saying?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So basically you're going to try and get to the inside and see what you can find in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so you cut it open and start pulling the interior out, the inside out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume I'm familiar with gutting sharks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Totally.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is just a lot harder because the skin is a lot thicker.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy's a lot bigger and the parts are all there the way they should be, but it takes a little bit of time.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, you get into the inside of it and you start going through the interior and you pull out a Toli head.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's there.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was obviously...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not his head, it's actually his torso.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the shark got away.
[SPEAKER_00]: You go through the rest of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm still looking!
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm just saying what I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: When he pulls up the head, I'm like, ah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You go through it into the contents after about a half hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you're probably throwing this stuff over the side.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no fair wind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it is...
[SPEAKER_01]: Boat-like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_03]: The big shirt was like- He's gonna go Captain- Oh, he's gonna go Captain- He's standing on it like, hmm.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bro.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's getting open and wiggling in.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yay!
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll sail this back to Monmurg, man.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tie the barrels on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tie the barrels on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I cast Invisible and I go back up and down to her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude and I will be gone for a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll be right back.